someone.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
Continuing
in the final verse of surah al
it's chapter number 73 verse number 20
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says
He says, "Subhan,
and nothing that you all put forth for
yourselves of good, no matter how small,
everything and every little thing you
put forth for yourselves of good, you
will find it with a law
and it will be there in its totality
better
and of greater consequence and reward.
This here is one of the rhetorical
contraptions used in the Quran very
often.
This pronoun here
who
Bamir.
Had
Quran.
home.
[Silence]
This statement when Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala says for instance in the fifth
verse of Bakar Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
says and those individuals
indeed they
are the truly successful
indeed those individuals
They are the truly successful. That
addition of they here.
Do we need this this addition in
order for the sentence to be correct?
Grammatically the sentence is correct.
They are and those individuals are the
successful ones. That addition of they,
what does it add to the sentence? It
adds
emphasis.
And so Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala in this
verse what is he saying? He is saying
subhanahu wa'ta'ala
that nothing you put forth for
yourselves, no matter how minuscule, no
matter how tiny, no matter how
forgettable,
anything that you do that is considered
of good, even if it's a grain of
sand, even if it is the weight of a
tiny ant,
even If it is a a piece of dust, if
it is good, Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
will never lose it. It will never be
misplaced.
And it will be
there for you on the day of judgment
when you come forth before Allah, it
will be there. And not only will it be
there, he tells us
that not only will it be there with
Allah, but it will be there better than
what you gave and of greater consequence
and reward. In itself it is greater and
in its context it is far superior
because Allah subhanahua
is ever more generous than his servant
and that's why one of the names of Allah
is a shakur a shakur what does the name
a shakur mean? A shakur means the one
who is worthy of all thanks
and it also means the one who thanks
those who strive for his sake subhanahu
wa ta'ala. The word has both meanings.
the one who is worthy of thanks and also
the one who thanks those who strive in
his way and he gives them more than they
put forth. So when we do something
these things we we may do some good
thing. It might be something off the
cuff. It might be something that we
didn't plan for. Something that is
little more than a little bump in the
road. something that we are prone to
forget and overlook. How however Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala misplaces not one
good deed. Even if it is done in the
deepest darkest place on this earth, it
will light it up. And so Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala is telling us
There's an narration in
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
he says to us and so
you know in this in this verse it's very
important that we understand the
emphasis that is placed on our deeds not
being misplaced.
He says,
"So any good deed that you do of good
and you put forth for yourself,
right?"
Means that you you put it forth for
yourself. You present it. This is your
presentation to Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala. This is what you're putting
forth for yourself.
almost a trust fund that you
are putting for yourself with Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. Anything even if
it's tiny, we never ever ever overlook
it, no matter how small it is, the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam tells us
[Silence]
He says
in the narration of
he says
do not ever belittle any good deed that
you will do
even if it is as simple even if it is as
impromptu as
meeting your brother with a welcoming
face.
The prophet sallall.aii wasallam tells
us in a narration
in
Bkari narration of Malik. He says,
[Silence]
he says,
"If the hour starts,
imagine
the heavens are splitting, everything is
falling apart,
And in your hand is a palm chute. A palm
chute is a baby palm tree. There's
reward in planting palm trees, date palm
trees. And you have in your hand a baby
palmoot
if you are able to stick it in the
ground
before the hour start.
If you are able to stick it in the
ground before the hour starts, then do
it.
You know what's interesting?
What's interesting is that our deeds,
they are twofold. They are beneficial to
this world, but more importantly, we are
worshiping Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
with these good deeds. whether those
good deeds pan out with some fruit or
not. If they yield a fruit, great. If
not, great. We're still planting.
So, for instance, what is the last thing
our prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
did before he passed away? Who could
[Arabic recitation]
A man is dying. You're dying. Would you
think to brush your teeth? I have a few
moments left. Let me brush my teeth.
Said that she was standing there or she
was sitting. His head was in her lap and
her brother Abdul Rahman was there and
he had a siwak and he was brushing his
teeth and she noticed that he looked at
it and so she said, "Would you like
this?" He nodded and so she took it. She
bit the ends off to give it that those
bristles and then she gave it to him.
She said,
She said, "So he brushed his teeth more
thoroughly than I have ever seen him
before do."
And then he uttered his final words. His
final words were what?
Say it loud. Say it.
[Arabic recitation]
or
oh Allah
I choose the higher companionship
then he passed away sallallahu alaihi
wasallam his last act of worship was
brushing his teeth because the prophet
sallallah
said
he said that brushing the teeth is a
purification for the mouth and a
pleasing sight to Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala. It's an act of worship.
And so he couldn't move. He couldn't
stand. He couldn't pray. He couldn't do
anything. But what could he do? He could
move his hand and do this last act of
worship. Why? Because maybe, just maybe,
that last final act is what tips the
scales. Maybe just that last final act
is the difference between one level of
paradise or the other. Of course, for
our prophet sallallah.aii wasallam, he
is guaranteed the highest. However, for
every one of us, we are not to squander
a moment. And what does a shaitan do to
get in your way? What does he tell you
when you go to do something good? He
comes to you. He says, "Oh, this one
good thing after what you've just been
doing. You just a half an hour ago you
were doing this and this and this and
this and now Mr. Tawa here right now you
want to come and act you're
worshiping Allah." Or he'll come and
say, ", so
you want to do this little thing, but
you and I both know you can't keep this
up. Tomorrow you'll be right back to the
way you were before.
That's how he is. That absolute
pessimism and negativity
to try to
to try to hinder you. If he can get you
off the path, he will. If he can get you
crooked on the path, he will. If he can
get you to stop on the path, he will. If
he can get you to just slow down a
little bit, he will. This is the way
that he does. He'll take what he can
get.
He'll take what he can get. And so those
final moments are critical. Abu Mus Ali
was laying on his deathbed.
Abu Musi is one of the greatest scholars
of all of the companions.
Abu Mus Ali
is such a scholar and is of such status
that the prophet sallall.aii alaihi
wasallam chose him as one of his
representatives in all of Yemen.
He was sent to the south part of Yemen
along with who was the other person that
was sent to Yemen.
Huh?
Those are his two representatives.
Right. And so he sent Abu Mus as his
representative. How much knowledge could
this man have had? Incredible. And he is
Yemen by origins.
When Abu Mus Ali laid on his deathbed,
he was drawing his final breaths. He was
in his final moments. His sons were
around him, his children, his family,
which is something that the new age,
right? The new age of what is the best
thing about the internet and and
technology and social media, it helps us
connect with each other. We've never
been more lonely and disconnected.
But the way it was is that when you die,
your family comes around, right? They
sit with you and they stay with you and
they alhamdulillah the Muslim we still
have a lot of that
a lot of that however it is quickly
dwindling the point Abu Mus Ali is
laying on his bed he is laying on his
deathbed he's drawing his final breath
his sons and daughters around him are
just devastated their father's dying
and so he said to his sons He said to
his children,
he said, "My sons,
my children,
don't ever forget the story of the man
and the loaf of bread."
What is the story of the man and the
loaf of bread?
He said
there was a man
who was a
he who was a monk. He stayed worshiping
Allah in his in his little retreat in
his hut
for 70 years
70.
And this man would come into the town
once a week to gather supplies, buy
food, whatever it is, and then head
right back to his s where he was in deep
meditation and worship in a constant
way. And so one day after 70
years of worship,
he came into the town
and a prostitute caught his eye. Woman
caught his eye.
He says
that he then was seduced and spent seven
days with her. One week. Seven days
doing what? Making making
cookies and and and crocheting you
know and and making muffins to to
pass out to the town's folks. No. Seven
days in Zena.
He said,
"And after seven days,
he kind of came to his senses. He
snapped back." What causes a person to
snap back when the illusion drops?
Because at first, the illusion is very
seductive. Oh, you know, he sees this
woman and her smile has the key to all
happiness, right? But then slowly over
time the illusion wears thin until
finally his he came back to his senses.
Abu Musa said that the man got up and
started to walk. He was in shock of what
he had done.
He said, "And so with every step he
would fall in prostration
and repentance to Allah."
And he kept walking and walking and
walking and walking and walking until
finally he ended up in some village.
and he found a group of poor men sitting
outside of you know on the side
of the path and there's a church
there or something. You know how people
gather poor people they panhandle
there and they wait. Well, these folks
are waiting because one of the priests
or monks from the church or s comes out
every day and gives them each a loaf of
bread. There were 10 of them.
So he came and he just kind of threw
himself between them.
And so
one of the
priests came out
and he started to distribute the 10
loaves of bread as per usual. But now
there's more than 10. There's 11 guys.
So he gives them out and our friend
He gets one.
That leaves one other guy that usually
would get it. A poor man who didn't get
one. So he said to the man, he said,
"Ain't noi, what about my loaf? You
didn't bring me my loaf of bread."
He said, "Do you see me having any more
loaves of bread?" They were 10. I gave
them out.
I got nothing for you. This is all I
have.
And so
he took that loaf of bread that was in
his hand and he gave it to that man
and he died. That was his dying act.
Abu Musa said he's brought before Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala.
And 70 years of worship
were voided by those seven days. A
person may say, "Hold up a second. Time
out. How could 70 years of warship be
voided by seven days?" Who can tell us
the answer to that?
Huh?
Passion.
Because those 70 years had a level of
enthusiasm to them. Those seven days
were what did he lose? Intense. every
fiber of his being was in it.
And those 70 years not as intense. It's
not about quantity. It's about
substance.
And so yes, 7 days of burning,
engulfing passion can can equal 70 years
of half steps
and reluctancy,
he said. And then this one loaf of bread
was brought and placed on his scale of
good deeds and he entered paradise
because of what? One loaf of bread that
he gave.
So what is Abu Musa saying? He's saying
I'm on my deathbed here,
but we don't know what deed of ours is
that loaf of bread. Do you know which of
your deeds is the loaf of bread? Who who
here can raise his hand and tell me he
is definitely going to Jenna? For sure.
Guaranteed. I'm in paradise. I know it
for a fact. I'm great. I'm fantastic.
I've done everything great. The world
could not go on without me. Right? That
kind of behavior. Not one of us. All of
us is guilty. Can any one of us raise
his hand and tell us that he's not
guilty?
He is not guilty. Every one of us is
guilty.
But not every one of us is sure that we
have given that loaf yet. We're not
sure.
And that's why the prophet sallallah.aii
wasallam tells us and we will end with
this inshallah.
He says a man in will be brought on the
day of judgment
and he has 99
scrolls of bad deeds.
[Arabic recitation]
the eye can see. All of that is what?
Bad deeds.
And those are then placed in the side of
the scale for his bad deeds. The prophet
sallallah.aii alaihi wasallam says the
man is then sure that he is doomed
and then it will be said to him
hold on we have one good deed left for
you to put in your scales of good deeds
and you will not be wronged or undercut
and then one will be brought out what is
a A small piece of paper that's a
will be brought out on written on it is
he said it with his heart filled with
certainty
and it will be placed in his scale of
good deeds.
to hold
and his good his bad deeds will then
will then shoot up meaning the side of
the scale when it is it is so heavy
those good deeds will then shoot up and
he will be admitted into paradise.
So Allah tells us
[Silence]
and seek Allah's forgiveness and pardon.
And with that, we will have concluded
the 74 73rd chapter.
Tomorrow night inshallah we will begin
which
what's the what's the order so far?
We started with
we started with right and then
and now we will go to
a person might look at this and say
you're going real slow in this. That's
the point. We're going very slow. You
know why? Because all of us have already
read these verses these chapters and we
are going too fast.
We need to stop at each concept and
absorb it because how was this book
revealed
over time 23 years? If our taps is 23
years long, if it goes for 24 years,
then tell me I'm going too slow. Once we
get to 24 years, say sh now that's too
slow. Now,
Now,